bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got yop
here with me thank you so much for doing
this
thanks thanks for having me anthony for
sure let's just jump right into
your background what did you do before
remote.com
i have a background in neuroscience so i
worked as a neuroscientist for a number
of years
and i left that because i discovered
hacker news and i wanted to be part of
tech
i started first by starting a startup it
went nowhere i
ran out of money within three months and
i had zero money left
so i had to find a job i started working
as a programmer somewhere in the
netherlands
and there i met sid who was starting
this crazy little startup and he was
like yeah
maybe you should join me uh the startup
did not be gitlab um
so i joined the team when it was founded
and uh helped grow that still
500 employees or so for five years i
left gitlab specifically to found remote
so that's a
real short story we got to talk about
git lab real quick because i think
there's a lot of people who
who find that story fascinating what was
your biggest learning or take away from
those five years i think the single
biggest learning was that
you can build a highly successful team
without ever having an office
without you know ever seeing your
colleagues or at least
maybe once a year do that all online and
not just
you can do it i think the one thing that
we've learned is that
there are so many advantages to doing
that that
you know and everybody's learning this
today that this is probably the
preferred way
of building a business it's it's much
more efficient and it gives significant
more freedom to individuals
you just have to learn to live without
an office so what is the
secret to doing it though right it's we
know it's possible we see some examples
gitlab i think is the largest remote
company in the world what is the secret
to making it a high performance team
uh that's uh that's a good question
i don't think there's one secret i do
think that there's a few realizations
you have to make one is
you get a lot of stuff for free with an
office you walk into the office you see
your colleagues
you see them at the water cooler all
those like micro interactions even just
seeing people at their desk
you get them for free in an office you
completely lose them in a remote setting
but they need to be replaced
and it means that because what do they
do they help build cohesion really in
your team they have make sure that
people bond with each other and it makes
that they have a better rapport with
each other and it makes working together
easier and collaboration easier and
you know there's more serendipity as
people often say
and so in a remote setting you get a lot
of stuff for free but that you don't get
for free
and what you have to do to solve that is
you have to create those moments where
people come together
there is not an agenda or not
necessarily an agenda
there is maybe something that you know
takes away your focus so that you're not
just
focused on talking with each other and
it can be playing a game
having like just a hangout together you
know virtual drinks whatever else
but you need to create those kind of
moments uh and you need to do that
consistently you have to do that at
different times to accommodate for
people's schedules
you have to do that um for different
interests because not everybody's
interested in hanging out
in a particular way not everybody is
interested in in games and so
that takes significant efforts to be
able to achieve that
but if you do achieve that that
basically solves the biggest problem of
remote work which is that yeah
the feeling that you lose certain you're
feeling that you lose this office
sense so it sounds like intentionality
becomes
a core piece um what about like
systemization of stuff i think that's
one thing i've heard from a lot of folks
uh is just like you've got to build
different types of systems
but also a lot more systems because
you've got to be more intentional about
how the work gets done yeah i think the
most fundamental thing is is that you
have to think about
the single source of truth for any piece
of information
and in that single source of truth you
have to log
everything every decision every action
every event
and so that means that if you are
talking about your company culture for
example there has to be a company
handbook
everybody has to regularly contribute to
that
and update it everybody has to regularly
read it and search through it
that's the simplest of things and it's
basically if you start a remote
organization
open a company handbook but this relates
to literally everything you do
if you are working on a project and use
some project management tool
then you have to make sure that if you
and i have a discussion about something
about a particular task in there that we
write down this is what we discussed and
this is the conclusion we have
and if you don't do that what is going
to happen is that you're going to create
an organization where people have to
constantly being each other
and they have to call each other they
have to send each other slack messages
and this is actually one of those things
that you hear very often right like
i hate working remotely because i feel
like i'm always being attacked by
notifications and the problem is is that
you have to you're not writing things
down people can't self-serve to the
information
and so you have to create a system for
this and the system has to be
write everything down write down
decisions write down actions it doesn't
have to be
good it doesn't have to be long it
doesn't have to be elaborate it has to
be just be
something if you write something down
that's a lot
much better than nothing and that
something has to live
in the one place where you write things
down so you can you can you can also not
have like
you know google docs is a great tool but
really bad for this because
they're hard to parse through and you're
going to end up with a million docs and
you're going to have to ping people not
to ask what is the outcome but you're
going to ask them well where is this
google doc
and so you need to have like a tool like
notion or you know if you use project
management tool like asana
where you write down this is where this
information lives and everybody knows
where to find it
that is absolutely fundamental without
that your organization is going to be
feel horrible because you always have to
be on calls
yeah it's so funny too because what the
intentionality and the systemization
really does is it leads to a more
efficient organization as well like
there's something to be said if you took
that same intentionality and brought it
to
the regular workplace how much more
productive would people be in office as
well
right so that makes a lot of sense uh i
want to go through a hypothetical
situation right you've built a number
of remote teams you run a company that
is specifically focused on people
running remote teams
and the hypothetical situation is i
today i run a business it's fully
centralized i want to run a remote
organization
how do i basically remote uh enable my
business so kind of
let's start at the very beginning i made
the decision okay i want to become a
remote organization
what do i do what are those first steps
or first considerations that i should
look at yeah i think everything exactly
was
i i was just saying you have to have a
place for documentation even if it's
just to write down like this is how we
work
and many offices don't have that because
you know you walk into the office
of your desk that's how you work if you
have a meeting you go to the meeting
room so you start there
i'm gonna create some sort of
documentation where everybody can
contribute and
help that help expand that and i'm going
to write down
this is how we work and how we work
starts with
we all work 100 of the time remote it
means that you can be in the office you
can be at home you can be the other side
of the planet
but your behavior should always be the
same and those behaviors are exactly
what i was just saying which is
you write down decisions you write down
processes
as a new process come up or processes
that might exist
right change and anything that you do
has to be remote accessible so even if
everybody is still going to the office
you know most of the days you have to
start running meetings as if
a remote participant might join and that
means that if you're in an office
and you know and you sit in a meeting
room you have to have a setup there that
make sure that people can join from the
outside
or and this is actually what we end up
doing sometimes at gitlab
is we were in the same building but
everybody sat behind their laptops on
zoom which feels very weird
but it's very useful because it makes
that the difference between remote
participants and local participants is
is near zero everybody has the same
exact view that is where you start you
start by writing those decisions down
and saying
this is how we work everything else
is essentially secondary it depends on
like what your preferences are i think
you know the most and we see this at the
remote very frequently because of what
we do but
the the nicest thing is that the moment
you start doing that you realize that
there's no necessity to be in the office
anymore and if there's no necessity to
be in the office
you know the pool of people that i can
hire goes from the ones that want to
live close to the office or live
already close to office to literally the
entire world and that's of course
you know very powerful so after i decide
okay i'm going to do documentation i'm
going to be remote first 100
remote as you described it how do i go
about evaluating these tools right it
feels like everyone now sees that
there's this remote shift happening and
everyone's building tools all over the
place
uh and rather than being attacked by
notifications i'm attacked by all these
different product pitches
uh what are some of the things i should
look for in the tools
or how should i go about evaluating what
actually is going to be effective for me
and my organization
yeah this is space is moving incredibly
fast so
like what i'm going to say today is
going to be completely outdated in a
year from now so i'm going to be very
careful about that
i think there's a big difference in
tools made for small teams
compared to large teams and with small
teams i mean you know
teams smaller than 20 or so people you
will have to make decisions for the
entire organization so if your
organization is significantly larger
the amount of tools that you can
actually use becomes very very very very
slim
first thing don't go too crazy with
tools
you don't want to have a million tools
like it just overwhelms people
right the onboarding experience of
joining organization being told like
well these are the 20 tools we use
and then you have to learn what
information goes where that's not a good
experience so
that's where i would start i would start
very simple you need something to do
video calls
if your team is big it has to be zoom
nothing else supports large amount of
teams right at remote we have like 100
something employees
zoom is the only one that will really
work but if you have a smaller team
there's loads of amazing companies like
for example whereby that
build really nice video tools and then
it's just a matter of flavor like what
do you
what do you like what do you it doesn't
really matter it just has to get a point
across
beyond that i would say um as we were
discussing earlier
there has to be some sort of tool that
gives you a sense of presence
and the best way to easily reach this
is to have an audio only tool so you can
use zoom for this
but it's actually kind of heavy weight
and there's lots of really great tools
that you can use specifically for this
and
the whole purpose of the tool should be
i join a room
or whatever your channel and i can talk
with my colleagues while also doing
other work so it feels like
easy low threshold to join it doesn't
feel like heavy like the people are
watching
me while i'm doing it and i i can talk
with my colleagues and i can easily
leave or switch channels
and there's also lots of tools for this
tandem is pretty good which connects
directly to slack
but what we use at remote for example we
just use discord which is
you know used by millions of people
around the world and
it's actually really really great for
this and then you know the documentation
piece is really tricky
there's very few tools today that are
good let alone
tools that are great at scale i would
say that there's
zero tools that are great at scale at
gitlab we
did it fully custom we used git lab we
published that as a static website and
it was good because it forced us to
build a lot of features into gitlab to
make it easier to use that but it's
still not like the ideal experience
i think tools like notion and
slides and coda and almanac
those are really great tools to do this
but they are not yet made for very large
teams so
at remote today we use notion internally
and you know notion had a bunch of
downtime recently that's very painful if
that's like your most important source
of information
but also it's like we have so much
information there today that you know
the search is not very good so
that's still very early days my answer
to that is like literally just try out
what works for you like like
it's very early days i think none of
them are good enough
yet to like support larger teams but if
your team is like you know below 20
people can you basically use all of them
make it all
pretty pretty good and that's it and
then beyond that you probably already
have a project management tool
if it's not online or accessible online
i don't know what tool you're using so
probably already
good in terms of tools and you know i
would say
you know make a decision in your company
about how you like what kind of
communication is expected so um you have
teams that say well we are fully
asynchronous so we
it's not important to be responsive to
messages in slack for example
there's many teams that nowadays choose
to like not use slack
at all and they use something like twist
or the new one that was just released
quail which looks really nice
um but most teams just use slack and
it's fine or microsoft teams
um and then um that's basically it
beyond that
it's it's all the tools that you're
already using project management tools
crm etc
so one of the things i want to talk
about is this idea of asynchronous
communication versus synchronous uh
first just describe kind of the two
different camps of thought and then what
you see as the pros and cons between the
two
yeah i mean i i don't think it's one for
the other i think that's that's an
important start
right now we are talking synchronously
right we're in the same time for the
same location directly replying to each
other which is very good
and it's not it's the most personal way
to communicate and it's
great for a quick back and forth uh if
we were to do this asynchronously what
would happen is you would ask me a
question i would answer it whenever i
wanted
which makes the cycle time of having a
conversation
extremely long the advantage of
asynchronous communication
is that if there's no expectation of
a direct answer it means that i can
reorganize my own time so
i can have a block of work in the middle
of the day of four hours where i say
i'm doing deep work and i'm not
responding to any incoming things
notifications from slack and whatever
and then i squeeze in all the little
messages requests and everything else
in a particular block in the day and i'm
gonna respond to them there
that is really what asynchronous work is
all about that you get the freedom to
reorganize your own time and and respond
to things and approach whatever's best
for you
and uh there's two reasons to do this
one is that if you start working
remotely you
immediately run into you know the need
to have flexible time you don't have to
be in the office anymore
might as well just work whenever you
want and the second one is is that
if you do that and if you have flexible
time you
can hire from anywhere and people will
be in other time zones and they'll be
sleeping when you're working which is
which essentially makes this required
and so that's what asynchronous work
allows it's
very important to realize that it's not
one is not a replacement for the other
you can work asynchronous most of the
time
it's still very pleasant to just talk to
someone and if you have a quick back and
forth or if you really want to
collaborate on something
yeah you should probably just set up a
call or like work together at the same
time in like figma
on the design and that's essential to
work so i wouldn't necessarily
like the remotes we do a lot of
asynchronous work but we do a lot of
synchronous work as well it would be
impossible to
just actually now that i'm saying it uh
almanac this company that makes one of
these docks they did an async week
last week where they only worked
asynchronously so
there were no slack messages there were
no calls whatsoever there were no
scheduled meetings
and they only work asynchronously and i
think one of the things that happens if
you do that one
is you feel like you have a lot of time
to get work done it's great
but the downside is you feel alone
like you're just doing work by yourself
and over response to you
and that's that's not the most pleasant
experience so yeah
pros and cons of both but asynchronous
work is fundamental to making remote
work
work well i want to talk also about
another form of the synchronous
communication you alluded to it earlier
is this idea of almost
whether it's a zoom room right where
kind of somebody has a
personal room you can jump in at a
certain time and you know they'll be
there
whether it's some sort of audio
communication where everyone's just kind
of hanging out the audio's on
if you want to talk you could talk if
not then you're just all kind of doing
work
what do you find is uh one the best way
to do it you mentioned discord for you
guys but are there other
specific tools and then two like what is
the best way to implement something like
that is it literally just hey everyone's
going to get on at 11 o'clock we're
gonna stay on for two hours
uh and we'll figure it out or is there
more kind of intentionality to it
around uh maybe hey for the first 30
minutes we're gonna do something and
then there's an hour and a half
everyone just kind of being connected if
you want to talk you can like how do you
guys actually
run those time blocks where everyone is
in a synchronous situation
but it's a little bit more passive than
active yeah actually we do multiple
things
um and so and we use different tools for
different things so we have
uh six times a week bonding time which
is a 30 minute block
in two and it spread for me i'm in
europe so in the
early morning for me and in a late day
for me so that in one time i overlapped
with apac and the other time i
overlapped with the us because we have
people all over the world
and that's a zoom room and we tend to
have an icebreaker question
like you know what's the best food you
ever ate or you know something more
interesting than that
uh and that soon then everybody johnson
room opt in
and you just talk with each other but
then what we have is we have a hangout
and so what the hangout is it's always
open we use discord for this but there's
many tools there's a tandem that i
mentioned earlier but there's also tools
that simulate an office environment so
you have like a 2d map
you can walk around it like a branch for
example
and um those are always
on and so our discord audio channel is
always on and sometimes people leave
messages and slack to say like i am in
discord i'm hanging out there
but it's always on people just join
whatever they feel like
throughout the day and people go in and
in and out out and
yeah you just you set it up you create
an expectation about the organization
and then in the beginning
especially if your team is larger you
have to seat it a little bit so you have
to like especially as leadership
hang out there very frequently tell
people i'm hanging out here you know
come chat with me but over time people
start to pick it up and they
you know hang out there and chat with
each other um
but yeah it's just a matter of like
setting up the discord buying this app
and just
always having it on and it's it's nice
it actually creates this
idea of like there's some presence which
is you know one of the things that you
lose with remote work is a sense of
presence
and this helps them for sure uh let's
talk about off sites
uh so the whole idea of like bringing
people together physically
uh in the same location versus having
people be uh remote all the time what's
the best practices there and how do you
guys run those
yeah well since coffee we haven't done
anything but um
and before covet we were a very small
team and we would actually meet up every
single month because we were all
in the same country at the same uh at
the time so it was very very easy
um my but the way we we
are going to do it post vaccine at
remote is very similar to how we did it
at gitlab which is
once a year once every nine months bring
the whole company together
at great expense in a nice location in a
hotel
and for several days uh and it just
focuses on bonding and having fun so not
work getting work done not making plans
but just
about bonding within the team and then
provide budget so that people are
encouraged to meet up either locally
or even throughout the world so one
thing two of my colleagues at gitlab did
is they spent six months
traveling the whole world and they went
to different colleagues in different
countries and so we had a policy which
says it came down to
well you're going to get x budget if you
visit
one person so if you're going to visit
like 10 different colleagues
your budget increases um generally i
would say
we strongly encourage people to get
together because it's nice
and so at remote we have a policy we
will pay for lunch if there's like four
colleagues
coming together we will always pay for
lunch because we want them to do that
and then the time you spend however you
want it it's nice to work together but
it's also nice to just hang out
yeah and so i guess as part of this um
do you think about
bringing the entire team together at any
one point
uh or is it actually more advantageous
to say hey everyone in apac or everyone
in the us
everyone in europe um and almost do it
like on a team
uh product or like a division standpoint
like i guess you've been doing this for
so long like you've probably seen
people do everything and try all these
different things what what are the pros
and cons
yeah we tried both um and we it like we
kept doing and we're gonna do the same
with remote
at least having one everybody get
together a year
which is really hard to pull off because
it's not going to be everybody it's
going to be 70
75 or so uh some people have to fly for
24 hours you know if you're deep in
india you're meeting in the middle of
the u.s
it's horrible you're going to be people
that are going to get stuck
in you know in border control which also
happened a bunch of times
but it is something special you know i
the one thing that i you know remote
grew really fast over the past year
and sometimes i still have like is this
really real you know like we have our
all hands and i see like
100 people behind their camera but i'm
like is this real and i think the nice
thing about
like really bringing everybody together
is exactly that it's like
well you if it feels real and it's it's
nice to
you know have dinner with these people
and like see everybody together
it's something special there there's
something there and i think it's worth
spending the
money on um bringing teams locally
together or even just like particular
regions
has certainly similar kind of benefits
um but uh yeah it's more restricted it's
more
you know where you're gonna make the cut
off it's
it's more difficult to do i think what
works really well is you if you do it by
you know the sales team gets together
you know the sales team has an offsite
and yes
people still fly all over the world but
it's a smaller team which makes it much
more manageable for example
a team that works on particular product
absolutely
uh when you think through uh remote.com
go
back to you know last year uh before the
pandemic hits you've got this idea what
was that original idea
and then walk me through kind of what's
transpired over the last 12 months or so
because as you mentioned uh you have
grown very very quickly
yeah so i left gitlab specifically to
solve the problem we faced there which
is
every time we would interview someone
and then try to hire someone in a
country where never hired someone before
we are faced with how do we pay them how
do we
you know make sure we're compliant how
do we provide them benefits
and it turns out if you hire someone in
a different country you have to comply
with local labor laws and that
means you have to run local payroll and
to run local payroll you have to have a
local entity and a local bank account
it's a lot of work and so there's a
bunch of vendors in the world that tried
to solve that problem and they did
a terrible job so terrible that we would
lose employees because they said well i
i can't count on receiving my pay slip
or even my money on time
so remote was founded specifically to
solve
that problem and early on we thought
well we're just going to work with a
bunch of local partners and that's
you know that will allow us to do
exactly this what we discovered really
quickly was that
that is not viable for us um we want to
create like a
really excellent business we want to be
very fast but we also want to be very
cost effective
and the only way for us to really do
that is to vertically integrate
and so we founded remote in early 2019
and we spent you know about 14
16 months just setting up the
infrastructure so we could
be able to run payroll in at a time for
different countries only
and actually employ people um as
employer of records for other
organizations
so it took us a very long time and
um april last year we started opening
the doors to
you know run payroll provide benefits
etc for for uh employers
and i think in in may or so we started
with the first few employees
um and uh yeah we were starting to feel
already the pressure because
you know in march a cop it happened
across the world
suddenly there was a huge boom boom
related to remote work we had
we were called remote it's it's a pretty
good name to have in this time
and um the the amount was overwhelming
for us to be able to open a new country
it takes anywhere between
three months to more than a year and a
significant expense is very complicated
process
so we saw massive demand we tried to
expand to as many countries as possible
um and yeah so we went that year from
you know doing
nothing in revenue to doing millions in
revenue by the end of the year our team
scaling i think from
10 or 15 people early in the year to
over 80 by the end of the year today i
think about 140 internally
what's been the craziest part about it
all you mentioned earlier like when you
saw the wall of all the videos but
what's been like the biggest surprise
for the thing that just hit you and been
like wow this is working
uh yeah i the mission of the company is
to just provide opportunities to
to people everywhere and it i think it
is really cool
to see the amount of people that are now
able to like get
jobs really well paying jobs
with really amazing companies we see
really really cool companies
uh as our customers that hire people
literally all over the world
often in countries where you know i
didn't know where they were before until
we opened a branch there or
you know like i had no idea about and i
think one of the nice things is is that
we we look at the data and everybody
that is employed through us is really
well compensated like
really well compensated and that's very
inspiring because i
that's what i believe it i live in the
middle of nowhere myself and
i think like it doesn't really it should
not really matter where you live where
you grow up or where you have to be
because of
you know family reasons for example uh
you should still be able to earn like a
a great wage you know you should be able
to have an awesome job and like have a
good career you shouldn't have to move
to a particular city and
yeah we're seeing that that's possible
and that's that's that feels
you know when it was like one or two
people i was like yeah you know it's a
fluke man
these people don't know what they're
doing but now we have hundreds of people
employed through us and
yeah that's really really cool to see i
love it uh when you think about
the international hires payment
complexity is one of the
biggest nightmares when it comes to all
of this there's a lot of people who
think that uh
bitcoin or cryptocurrencies could be the
solution there uh you guys for
a number of reasons we'll get into can't
really use some of those uh
currencies or digital currencies as a
solution talk us through just what are
the problems first with the
international payment and payroll
and then we can talk about some of the
solutions that you've had to build yeah
um so payroll itself is complicated but
you can figure it out but the payments
are the real pain
so there's a lot to to unpack here first
off
if you are employed locally you have to
be paid in local currency
so if you're deployed in analysts you
get euro you know
if you're both the united states you
have to be paid in usd
those are easy in many countries
the local currency can be either highly
volatile
or it can just be very hard to find
anyone that can actually convert the
currency for you that's
actually it can actually be a problem on
top of that
um receiving money is
harder than it sounds in many different
places we often have
and often as in like literally every day
problems
paying directly into someone's bank
account in a particular location
either people don't have a bank account
which still happens there's a lot of
cash only places or bank account banks
are just unreliable
or hard to work with or don't support
you know modern ways of transacting
money
there's an infinite amount of problems
and then for us
specifically we have to we tend to have
a local bank account
opening a local bank about is incredibly
difficult it's harder to
open a local bank account than it is to
set up a local entity
uh in most cases i had to fly to
multiple countries and post covet i have
to do all sorts of weird things i
literally have
different colored pens on my desk
because i have to wet signs so many
documents every day like
it's the kind of stuff just to open a
bank account is crazy
and then once we're there it still tends
to be incredibly hard to just
work with them at all and then we as a
business we have to think about you know
our customers they
we invoice them in whatever currency
they want and then we want to pay out
directly in local currency
um but we have to account for currency
fluctuations and we have to somehow
deal with with effects there that's
that's really challenging as well and
then once you
think well you know what i'm going to do
is i'm going to hedge
right i'm going to hedge a little bit uh
on the currency
that's not allowed you can't do that you
have to have a specific license to to be
able to hatch a fund
so like okay well what we're going to do
is we're going to estimate
how much it's going to cost and then
we're going to charge this well now
instead of just like paying someone
salary you're charging for a product so
you have to charge
you have to pay taxes over that bid that
you're like that's your fake hedge
like there's no way out and we face this
every single day
and so you know we work with the number
of like really large partner banks
that have bank accounts all over the
world and it makes it easier
but it does not solve any of these
issues particularly
compliance issues they keep biting us
it's
it's a nightmare i i can tell that it's
what i would just listen to
talk about it and so the idea is that
like cryptocurrencies there it's uh
nearly impossible to use because of all
the compliance laws right so there's
there's uh technical solutions but they
don't meet the regulatory
uh solutions in some situations or they
aren't regulatory solutions and so
therefore you're basically pushed back
into
what ends up being likely inferior
technology that you have to use to to
comply correct yeah yeah that's
basically it yeah no
for sure it's inferior technologies it
can take days for for transactions to
to complete and even then they often
balance we have all sorts of problems
with it
no cryptocurrency has a huge potential
to solve these kind of things but it's
never allowed
we always have to pay in local currency
there's exceptions to this like if
someone is a contractor they're willing
to
accept it or um you know you could
imagine
we haven't done this but you could
totally imagine like setting up
something local
that then automatically converts into
cryptocurrency if everybody
you know uh agrees with that but it's
never allowed for us to directly pay
someone in a cryptocurrency if they're
legally employed by us
you know in fact the local governments
are nowhere near
in terms of bureaucracy in terms of laws
nowhere near thinking about
cryptocurrency they are not even aware
of the state that you can hire someone
in a different country
right like that's in itself already a
thing that we have to fight
in the majority of countries in which we
operate we have to explain what we do
and then they say oh you mean offshoring
we said no companies just hire great
people that i just happen to live in
your country
and like that's already a break of it
especially but
but still today it's a really big
challenge that we face and so
um yeah i uh yeah it's horrible
cryptocurrency really it is a solution
like it is a solution it would be great
if we could just you know
use bitcoin for all of this and it it
would totally solve everything it would
be instant you would have it wherever
you want it we don't have to worry about
borders but now we are constantly
thinking about all sorts of bank
accounts we have virtual bank accounts
for
customers employees and then we have to
transact locally it's
yeah it's a nightmare when you think
about uh kind of zooming out
and looking forward five or ten years uh
is every company remote
are there still companies that are
heavily centralized going into offices
uh
is it kind of a coexistence like
decentralized uh in-office companies
have a remote option just
where do you think this is all going
yeah i think
there's a few things i think not
everybody wants to work from home
right so you're gonna want to have a
place out of your home to be able to
work from and i think
you know there will be plenty of
companies that uh will provide
office space of course there's plenty of
co-working spaces and those will
continue to do better and better but
there will be many
uh companies that will continue to to
have offices or
or even prefer to have offices what i do
think is that
um governments and laws are pushing for
you know
like sort of forcing remote work in a
lot of ways we see this in the
netherlands where the law essentially
states like
unless there's really good reason that
you cannot do your work remotely
any individuals should be allowed to do
all of their work remotely if they
please
and that's the direction we're going
into especially for like tech companies
or companies that
have you know valuable talent it's it
it's it's not doable to just seeking
your immediate uh surrounding anymore
like you
if you want to hire find a great
developer there's thousands
right now looking for a remote job
but if you happen to live in location x
there might be three around you so
um we all see a push in law
towards allowing remote work but i think
in in reality
there's going to be many companies that
will still have offices but more they
will go to like flex kind of offices
or you know offices where you know a
small subset of the people
uh will be there will be notable uh
exceptions i think i think companies
that will say well we are we like to
work from the office and i think there
will be many people that are very loudly
will proclaim
i will always work from an office but
it's to be expected i think
i think it's fine like we will never get
an office at remote other than the ones
that
local governments force us to have of
which we have a few
um if we were to have a big office i
would also enjoy going there like i
don't i'm not the person that's like
against that i just
i just value the freedom that remote
work gives me more than
being in that kind of office and that's
the trend i think it will come
i think it makes a ton of sense uh and
it feels like to me this is the trend
that is not going to slow down at any
time soon
before we get into the rapid fire
questions to uh to wrap it up and then
you'll get to ask me one question
where should we send people to find you
on the internet or find more about
remote.com
well yeah remote is very easy remote.com
i can't get it wrong
uh and me uh you can email me directly
users yop at remote.com or you can
find me on twitter which is my first
name vo yopvo
all right before we get into rapid fire
how did you get the url there's got to
be a good story here
now someone else was running business on
it so i i said you know
i have a good idea i i think i could do
better what you're doing right now
um and i'm lucky that like the owners of
them they uh they worked with me and my
co-founder marcelo and
um you know we came to agreement there
are small shower holders in remote today
so that's that's how it worked out
so i don't like to say that it was
expensive i think it's probably an
understatement given how well remote is
doing
i was going to say they're probably very
very happy that they uh did that deal
right
there they're they're you know they are
entrepreneurs themselves and they're
doing
doing well but yeah i don't think they
might i love it
um all right first question is what is
the most important book that you've ever
read
um i think it's it's
the man who has to mistook his wife for
a hat from by all of her sex
uh it's a really really fun book it's
not very long it's like 200 pages
and the reason why i say that book is
because that sets me off from like
studying
neuroscience uh becoming a great
deterministic person in sense of like
how i think about the world
um and and that in neuroscience i think
that i got the foundation of the person
who i am and how i think about things
which is
you have to really know your [ __ ] that's
how i think about it like if you do
if you don't know something you just
shut up and you make sure that you
figure out what and that yeah so and
that book basically started all that off
i loved that book and i read it through
it in like one day
and and that's the start of the whole
journey that's
a great suggestion uh second question is
more personal sleep schedule
i used to not sleep at all and then our
friends over at eight sleep
uh got me on this thermoregulated bed i
basically crank it as cold as possible
sleep like a baby sleep eight or nine
hours now and feel like my life's been
changed
uh what is your sleep schedule and how
has that changed over time
i wanted an eighth sleep so bad i don't
think they shipped them to portugal or
the netherlands i wanted so bad
um i'll help you get one don't tell
anybody okay good
yes thanks um yeah they're gonna kill me
for every time i talk to somebody in
europe like they don't ship here i'm
like
let's see what we can figure out we'll
figure it out yeah no
that's awesome yeah i really want one um
i have two kids below
one of two in one of uh seven months so
obviously
i go to i work really hard uh i take
care of them
and so i sleep when they let me and i
wake up whenever they wake up
so this morning you know last night i
went to bed at 11 and i woke up at
6 30 because my daughter jumped on me so
that's
it i uh i have two types of people who
don't get
great sleep either workaholics or people
with young kids those are the two
times when people don't get good sleep
so you fit in one category for sure
uh last question is about aliens are you
a believer or a non-believer
no i think there's a good uh chance that
there's some life
somewhere given the size of the of the
of the universe and the amount of stars
and planets there are
i think one interesting thing i think
about very often is how
how poorly we can actually observe the
universe directly from the earth or even
through satellites right if you
think about if we think about like how
many moons jupiter has for example you
know we're like oh there's a lot of them
but now and then
there are some that we are we're not
sure if there's an another moon there
could be another moon you're like
with the solar system we know that
really really well and if you think
about like
the fact that we know that so poorly and
that universe is so incredibly big
like yeah i think it's
reasonable that there's life somewhere i
i wouldn't and you know
i i'd be curious to see it or meet it
whatever
whatever it would be yeah i i definitely
think there's life out there somewhere
so we'll see
what one question you have for me to uh
to finish up
yeah i mean you know we think a lot
about creating opportunity anywhere and
sort of
blurring borders right i think borders
are
you know the bane of my existence um and
i i think the internet helps a lot with
that and i think you know tools like
like zoom and it's easiest but in the
future like vr
and ar uh what do you think
the future of countries is like will
there still be countries
in i don't know how many years i think
there will definitely be countries i
kind of think of that as like that's a
manifestation of the physical and analog
world right is uh people will always
argue over who owns what land and where
the line is
and you know all that kind of crazy
stuff uh and then you know
there's a very strong argument for good
governance right and i think that it's
easy for us all to latch on to the bad
governance
of governments and say you know look at
these idiots they're just wasting money
and and making our lives harder but uh
but they do provide a lot of
good benefits as well in in cases right
everything from uh
national defense all the way on down and
so i think that um
it's not a thing of like will they ever
disappear it's more so like what will
they look like
and i think the part that i'm most
excited about is uh
competition in the open market so if
people can now live wherever they want
uh governments will compete for those
citizens and you see that you know
inside the united states you see cities
and states and doing it kind of on
a more micro level uh but on the macro
level you're going to see countries do
it and so
if all of a sudden you can choose
between you know estonia
singapore portugal the united states uh
you know i don't know argentina
or nigeria where are you going to go
like there's a couple of core things
that people care about and so i think
that
having that competition is a good thing
it'll ultimately breed
kind of much stronger nation states and
much more attractive environments for uh
for the citizens that choose to work
within those nation states
but i think that that's probably one of
the most exciting yet
uh most misunderstood things about the
future like what is it look like i have
no clue
it just feels like free free market
competition is good for everyone right
yeah i that that's what i hope the
direction we're going into you know i
i have as an eu citizen i have a lot of
freedoms within the eu and even outside
of the eu
but i have friends you know from ukraine
for example that are
severely limited in where they can
travel and even if they
travel it's it's a pain even to like
very otherwise
you know very open countries um and my
hope is that you know borders dissipate
with with this competition and i'm
curious to see if everybody is going to
live in portugal where the weather is
always good or
whether you know it will actually be
more evenly distributed
you are portugal's number one salesman
i love it all right listen thank you so
much for doing this uh i
really really enjoyed it i think that uh
what you guys are building is obviously
a no-brainer
uh and uh the remote trend is not going
to slow down anytime soon so if anyone
out there is thinking about moving to a
remote organization or running one
uh i heavily suggest go check out
remote.com uh they pretty much have
everything you need in order to run your
organization
uh do payroll pay people et cetera and
do it all in a compliant way so
i appreciate the time left this again in
the future